[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
johanna pareigis
guten abend schön dass sie dabei sind
den sport hat norbert lehmann für sie
eine gute antwort von mir angesichts der
steigenden zahlen corona auch heute
natürlich ein großes thema
wer soll wann eine booster impfung
bekommen die impfkommission berät und
wird wohl eine auffrischung für alle ab
18 jahren empfehlen
streitthema impfpflicht für bestimmte
berufe lehrerinnen und lehrer etwa es
gibt immer mehr stimmen dafür die
künftige koalition wird bald entscheiden
müssen und
not und hunger in afghanistan erst kam
die dürre nun drohte winter dabei haben
hunderttausende schon jetzt nicht genug
zu essen
eine nationale kraftanstrengung fordert
die scheibe kanzlerin bei den
auffrischungsimpfungen bisher aber
herrscht ein durcheinander wer und ab
wann man sich eine oster impfung geben
lassen kann in berlin beispielsweise
geht das künftig schon fünf monate nach
der letzten corona impfung der
bundesgesundheitsminister will dass
bundeseinheitlich regeln und auch die
ständige impfkommission hat sich jetzt
zu wort gemeldet thomas concia
bei lanz und laudert dann erstaunen zur
vorgerückten stunde rückt stiko chef
merkens nebenbei mit etwas heraus
auffrischen das werde er empfehlen allen
ab
doch mit dem impfen gebe es ein problem
nämlich
stark gefordert das sieht so aus
telefone stehen nicht still dafür stehen
die patienten und zwar schlange boostern
boomt impfstoffes da ein termin oft
nicht das könnte sich noch verschärfen
wenn die stiko ihre empfehlung ändert
bis jahresmitte waren gut 31 millionen
volljährige vollständig geimpft sie
haben bis jahresende also sechs monate
später anspruch auf eine auffrischung
die wiederum haben schon 4,4 millionen
bekommen es bleiben noch 26,8 millionen
wuster berechtigte noch mehr werden es
wenn die dritt impfung schon er kommt
zum beispiel nach fünf monaten
so schaffen wir das nicht sagen
hausärzte und beklagen generell sehr
chaotisch kommunikation einfach
sozusagen das top down zu verkünden und
dann erst hat sich darum zu kümmern wie
können wir das tatsächlich alles auch
organisieren jetzt erstmal flexibel
selbst organisieren darum bittet
gesundheitsminister sparen die ärzte in
einem brief der vorgesehene abstand von
sechs monaten zur immunisierung ist als
zeitliche richtschnur zu sehen denn
natürlich nicht tages genau einzuhalten
ist dennoch gelte schwache zuerst sagt
er mit verfasser des briefs von der
stiko zunächst adressierten gruppen
machen und 14 bis 15 millionen menschen
aus das ist auch eine größere hunde zu
bewältigen ist würden es aber mehr zu
schaffen wäre das nur mit impfzentren in
berlin etwa laufen sie weiter in bayern
sollen sie reaktiviert werden auch
mobile zentren wie heute in hannover
will man wieder beleben
spontane schneller auffrischen ganz im
sinne der und politiker ein chaos aber
zulasten der schwächeren ganz sicher
nicht
neben der ausweitung der booster
impfungen wird derzeit auch über eine
impfpflicht für bestimmte berufsgruppen
diskutiert auch die fdp schließt die
nicht mehr grundsätzlich aus etwa für
pflegeberufe im brandenburgischen will
da wird jetzt versucht gezielt bestimmte
beschäftigte für auffrischungsimpfung
anzusprechen nicola albrecht hat sich
angeschaut wie das läuft der kleine
sitzungssaal im rathaus wildauer ist
heute für ein paar stunden eine
impfpraxis die stadtverwaltung hat zur
auffrischungsimpfung eingeladen
besonderer fokus menschen die viele
kontakte vor allem zu schutzbedürftigen
haben die erzieher marius hübner wenn
man dann praktisch die ganze zeit
eher weniger sauberen kindern unterwegs
ist dann ist das schon recht wichtig
weil wir sonst verteilt man ja alles und
alle kinder an alle familien die
impflinge in wilder sind dem aufruf
freiwillig gefolgt eine impfpflicht für
genau diese berufsgruppen wird aktuell
heftig diskutiert lehrer und erzieher
innen aber auch arbeitnehmer im
gesundheitswesen und der pflege müssten
zur impfung gesetzlich verpflichtet
werden fordern immer mehr ärzte und
wissenschaftler tatsache ist es gibt
personen die besondere berufliche
verantwortung haben für die man eine
impfpflicht durchaus empfehlen sollte
einträge von infektionen in diese
pflegeheime oder in krankenhäuser und
sind natürlich besonders fatal für die
betroffenen
gewerkschaften und berufsverbände halten
zum großteil dagegen testpflicht sei
wichtiger als eine impfpflicht
argumentieren sie druck auf eine vom
personellen notstand gebeutelte branche
sei kontraproduktiv
wer als verband lehnen eine impfpflicht
für pflegekräfte vehement ab wir glauben
allen ernstes nicht dass die die
wirklich gegen impfung sind
sich durch so etwas überzeugen lassen
die würden den beruf den rücken zu
kehren
in wildau wurde die impfaktion gut
angenommen über eine impfpflicht muss
die politik entscheiden
die impfquote ist weiter zu niedrig die
zahl der neuinfektionen schnellt
ungebremst in die höhe schon wieder
meldet das robert koch institut einen
neuen höchstwert innerhalb von 24
stunden wurden 52 1826 neue fälle
registriert das sind 13.000 150 mehr als
am vergangenen mittwoch
294 menschen starben im zusammenhang mit
prowin 19 binnen eines tages die
bundesweite sieben tage incidents liegt
aktuell bei
319,5
um die hohen corona zahlen runter zu
kriegen setzt die geplante ampel
koalition auf ein neues
infektionsschutzgesetz morgen bringen
spd grüne und fdp den gesetzentwurf im
bundestag ein unter anderem sieht den
heim eine bundesweite test pflicht vor
für alle die dort arbeiten oder zu
besuch kommen außerdem soll 3g gelten
und kontrolliert werden in bussen und
bahnen und an arbeitsplätzen in denen
kontakte nicht ausgeschlossen werden
können dann geschossen
lange hat sie die kanzlerin geschwiegen
am wochenende dann ein hinweis auf den
ernst der lage per podcast heute nun bei
einer veranstaltung des städtetags
kritisierte sie spd grüne und fdp für
ihren plan die epidemische lage
auslaufen zu lassen auch wenn es
rechtlich keine mehrheit mehr für die
fortsetzung der epidemischen notlage von
nationaler tragweite gibt kann es für
mich keinen zweifel daran geben dass wir
uns mitten in einer solchen notlage
befinden die ampel parteien verteidigten
ihre pläne das neue gesetz wurde die
entscheidung zurück in die parlamente
und zielgenau solche maßnahmen die in
zeiten verfügbaren impfstoff nicht mehr
verhältnismäßig sein diejenigen die zur
alten rechtslage zurückkehren wollen
könnten allenfalls wenn man sachlich
argumentierte nicht politisch
kommunikativ sein sachlich ja nur
verlangen es ist wir wollen wieder mit
note verordnungsrecht arbeiten oder wir
wollen pauschale flächen lockdown sprich
eine vollständige stilllegung des
öffentlichen lebens erreichen
eine öffnungsklausel soll es besonders
stark betroffenen bundesländern erlauben
auch künftig weiter reichende maßnahmen
zu beschließen etwa freizeit oder
kulturveranstaltungen zu beschränken
manches aber dürften auch die länder
nicht etwa veranstaltungen komplett
untersagen oder
gastronomieflächen decken schließen
einiges davon aber fordern nun unter
anderem die unionsgeführten länder nrws
neuer ministerpräsident hendrik wüst
droht in einem brief unter anderem an
olaf scholz das gesetz das morgen im
bundestag beschlossen werden soll
ansonsten übermorgen im bundesrat zu
blockieren seien nicht ausreichend und
nicht zustimmungsfähig ich kenne keinen
brief ich habe von einem brief gehört es
ist notwendig dass sich jetzt alle
unterhaken die sehr guten und sehr
intensiven beratungen zwischen allen die
hier verantwortung in deutschland haben
haben uns jetzt in die lage versetzt das
auch in dieser woche alle wichtigen
entscheidungen getroffen werden dafür
müsste man sich nun aber doch noch sehr
schnell einigen oder den
vermittlungsausschuss anrufen was
weitere zeit kosten würde
unionsgeführte bundesländer drohen also
damit am freitag im bundesrat dem
infektionsschutzgesetz nicht zuzustimmen
santala banerjee was bedeutet das das
bedeutet dass die union hier praktisch
ihre linie bei der korona politik
erzwingt und
22 dafür keine mehrheit mehr hat im
bundestag gelingen kann das bei wegen
eines sehr engen zeitplans bis nächste
woche donnerstag müsste ein
überarbeitetes infektionsschutzgesetz
das dann auch den ansprüchen der union
entspricht noch durch den
vermittlungsausschuss des bundestages
und noch einmal durch eine abstimmung im
bundestag und im bundesrat das wäre
unter normalen umständen schon sehr
ambitioniert zeitlich aber wie uns jetzt
gerade die bundestagsverwaltung noch
einmal bestätigt hat es kommt noch etwas
dazu nämlich der vermittlungsausschuss
des bundestages müsste sich überhaupt
erst neu konstituieren den gibt es so
aktuell nicht im neu gewählten bundestag
das macht das ganze noch einmal sehr
viel schwieriger und ob es dann
überhaupt gelingen kann diesen zeitplan
einzuhalten ist fraglich übrig bliebe
dann nur die verlängerung der
epidemischen lage so wie es sich die
union eben vorstellt was man wenn man
sich das anguckt sagen kann ist dass die
union sich hier in der opposition auf
jeden fall anders verhält als zum
beispiel fdp und grüne die in der
pandemien der vergangenheit auch dinge
mitgetragen haben gegen die sie
eigentlich inhaltlich gewesen sind danke
für diese einschätzung von talabani
sie wollen noch mal in ruhe nach gucken
welche corona maßnahmen geplant sind von
home office über testpflicht bis 3 g und
wie die bundesländer zusätzlich
verschärfen können dann schauen sie bei
uns online und in unserer zdf heute
es wird wohl bald ein weiterer corona
impfstoff zur verfügung stehen der
us-hersteller nova wachs hat jetzt eine
zulassung für die eu beantragt das neue
mittel zeigt eine wirksamkeit von 90
prozent und ist ein sogenannter tod im
stoff das heißt er enthält abgetötete
bestandteile des corona virus und kann
so das menschliche immunsystem
aktivieren
im zuge der pandemie haben sich die
korona leutner weiter radikalisiert so
warnte bundespräsident steinmeier heute
bei der digitalen herbsttagung des
bundeskriminalamtes verschwörungs glaube
oft gepaart mit blanken antisemitismus
bereitet den boden für angriffe auf
medien ins ärzte und wissenschaftler für
ein klima der spaltung und hetze was das
bedeutet zeigt das beispiel des
virologen martin stürmer er wird bedroht
stefan schlosser berichtet wie sehr die
pandemie den zusammenhalt der
gesellschaft auf die probe stellt haben
die großdemonstrationen gegen die korona
maßnahmen gezeigt ihre wut richten die
menschen nicht nur gegen politiker auch
gegen mediziner wie den virologen martin
stürmer anfeindungen und beleidigungen
erhält der regelmäßig vieles lässt er an
sich abprallen doch manchmal wird es
auch bedrohlich wenn die drohungen etwas
konkreter werden richtungs körperliche
gehen und wenn es dann so ist wie bei
uns einmal mit dem zaun wenn der zaun
tatsächlich geschmiert wird dann ist man
sehr nahe kommt das ganze sehr nahe und
da sind die diskussion auch im
familienkreis doch schon sehr intensiv
es ist nur eine kleine minderheit der
bevölkerung doch gerade im internet
finden sie gleichgesinnte bestärken sich
gegenseitig und stacheln sich an wir
sehen sehr wohl das risiko dass einzelne
und auch kleinere gruppen sicher weiter
radikalisieren sich in ihren echo kann
man selbst befeuern und wir müssen
darauf achten dass daraus keine
gewaltdelikte neue kriminalitätsformen
entstehen viele menschen sind mit der
korona situation überfordert ihre
existenzen teilweise bedroht sie suchen
ein ventil für ihre unzufriedenheit
das betrifft in vor allen dingen
menschen die im hohen maße den eindruck
haben gesellschaftlich nicht teilhaben
zu können vermutlich leute die auch
weniger zur wahl gehen laut menschen die
protest wählen weil sie sich eben
gesellschaftlich nicht repräsentiert
fühlen also im weitesten sinne im in die
demokratie wenig integriert sind martin
stürmer weiß genau er wird weitere
nachrichten mit beleidigungen bekommen
verstummen will er aber dennoch nicht
in mecklenburg vorpommern ist erstmals
die afrikanische schweinepest
ausgebrochen in dem betroffenen
mastbetrieb bei güstrow werden seit
heute die mehr als 4000 tiere getötet
die behörden haben um den hof eine
mehrere kilometer große sperrzone
eingerichtet
die schweinepest ist hoch ansteckend für
den menschen aber nicht gefährlich wie
genau der erreger den stall kam ist noch
unklar es gab bereits einzelne fälle in
sachsen und den banken
ins ausland als erstes an die grenze
zwischen belarus und polen dort hat sich
die situation offenbar etwas entspannt
nach polnischen angaben wurden
flüchtlinge von billa russischen
sicherheitskräften vom grenzer und
weggeführt offenbar werden sie zum
schutz vor der kälte in lagerhallen
untergebracht einige von ihnen sollen
morgen in den irak zurück geflogen
werden
in afghanistan leiden 19 millionen
menschen hunger das ist fast die hälfte
der bevölkerung
die situation hat sich nach der
machtübernahme der taliban dramatisch
verschlechtert denn die wirtschaft ist
so gut wie zusammen gebrochen und der
winter naht besonders schwierig ist die
situation auf dem land aus der provinz
wardak im osten des landes berichtet
katrin eigendorf
wir sind unterwegs in der provinz wardak
50 kilometer von kabul entfernt herrscht
extreme dürre die landwirtschaft gibt
nicht mehr genug her um den bauern das
überleben zu sichern sagte schaaf hat
uns in sein haus eingeladen als
tagelöhner versucht er seine elfköpfige
familie zu ernähren
meine kinder sind krank und ich kann
ihnen nicht die medizin kaufen die sie
benötigen es gibt keine arbeit ich
kämpfe mit den finanzen
von einem verwandten haben sie sich geld
geliehen doch davon sind nur noch
umgerechnet fünf euro übrig das reicht
gerade für brot und tee in
kabul verteilen die mitarbeiter des
world food programms mehl und öl
nothilfe für die an diesem morgen
hunderte anstehen marcia mohammadi
erzählt von so grosser not dass manche
familien sogar planen ihre babys zu
verkaufen
wir versuchen zu verhindern dass sie
ihre kinder verkaufen es gibt familien
die planen ihre kinder zu verkaufen um
das leben von vier oder drei anderen zu
sichern
bei ihrer arbeit können die helfer auf
unterstützung der taliban bauen die
taliban stehen unter druck sie wissen
ohne westliche hilfe droht dem land der
wirtschaftliche zusammenbruch und eine
hungerkatastrophe
das ist für den westen eine chance das
regime zu zugeständnissen zu bringen es
muss schnell gehen nach prognosen
internationaler hilfsorganisationen
drohen mit einbruch des winters mehr als
eine million kinder zu verhungern
das aktionsbündnis katastrophenhilfe
kämpft gegen den hunger mit ihrer spende
können sie helfen stichwort zdf nothilfe
afghanistan konto de 65 104 106 100 104
106 100 infos gibt's auch unter spenden
zdf.de und auf zdf textseite 890
er gilt als einer der bedeutendsten
ehrungen in der wissenschaft hierzulande
der deutsche zukunftspreis
bundespräsident steinmeier überreichte
den preis vor wenigen minuten an die
erfinder des krone impfstoffes der firma
biotec
das team um seo richie und uhr sahin
wird für die entwicklung des impfstoffes
ausgezeichnet nominiert waren auch
forschende aus münster die mit kautschuk
aus löwenzahn reifen herstellen sowie
forschend aus er lang sie entwickelten
ein kristall der bei der
computertomografie schärfere bilder bei
geringerer strahlenbelastung liefert und
mehr zum deutschen zukunftspreis gibt es
um 22 15 im zdf und jetzt kommt es zum
fußball zum sport norbert und da ist
eben männer u 21 nationalmannschaft ja
auch nach dem jüngsten 0 4 debakel gegen
polen nun ein wichtiger sieg gestern
abend das dfb team von trainer antonio
di salvo bezwangen die klaren
außenseiter aus san marino mit 4 0
deutschland hat damit die
tabellenführung in der quali gruppe b
verteidigt mit gleich fünf neuen
spielern in der startformation setzte
trainer deshalb ein deutliches zeichen
um sein team nach dem vorübergehenden
winterschlaf wieder wachzurütteln der
doppelschlag durch den schalker mali
knapp 14 minuten und nur eine minute
später durch den nürnberger eric
schulhof gab den trainer mit seiner
maßnahme recht eine herrliche
einzelaktion durch team captain jonathan
burkhardt von mainz 05 zum 13 0 noch vor
der pause sowie ein konter zum 4 0
endstand durch den kölner garantie mann
brachten das jahr für die deutsche u21
doch noch zu einem versöhnlichen
abschluss
ja und der ex trainer der deutschen u 21
europameister der war gestern abend auch
erfolgreich stefan kunz hat es mit der
türkischen nationalmannschaft auf den
letzten drücker in die playoffs zur wm
qualifikation geschafft durch das 2 2 1
in montenegro
ja und in südamerika hat nach brasilien
auch argentinien das ticket für die
fußball wm gelöst das team von superstar
lionel messi schaffte die quali trotz
eines torlosen unentschiedens ging dies
auch weil viele gegen ecuador verloren
ohne spielpraxis kann auch ein
argentinischer superstar nicht die
erhofften glanzlichter setzen aber
lionel messi war zugegen was die fans
schier in den wahnsinn trieb sein
vereinskollege aus paris der brasilianer
nene musste wegen muskelproblemen die
argentinische provinz amran
unverrichteter dinge verlassen die erste
halbzeit ohne nennenswerte torchancen in
der zweiten hälfte immer noch nichts
zählbares doch brasilien mit den
besseren möglichkeiten zum beispiel in
der 60 minute fred mit einem
lattenschuss in einem kampfbetonten
spiel ließ messi kurz vor schluss sein
können aufblitzen trotz dieser
nullnummer im clásico freut sich der
superstar auf seine fünfte wm teilnahme
das wars vom sport danken hat und wir
machen weiter mit großen leistungen denn
wenn rund um den erdball viele menschen
noch viel mehr erstaunliche dinge tun
als sonst ist wieder internationaler
weltrekordtag im handstand ein auto 10
50 meter weit innerhalb von 30 sekunden
so viele einbeinige salti oder kreise
mit dem bmx-rad zeigen oder einfach nur
unfassbares ball geschickt alles ist
erlaubt und wenn es nicht im ersten
versuch gelingt und auch nicht im
zweiten ist der jubel um so größer wenn
es am ende dann doch klappt
und jetzt noch die lottozahlen an diesem
mittwoch die gewinnzahlen lauten 5 15 21
28 47 superzahl ist die neun weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
das wetter noch auf morgen ist es häufig
trüb aber die sonne anteile die nehmen
doch zu mehr zum wetter gleich von katja
horneffer claus kleber begrüßt sie um 21
45 zum heute journal auf wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend die kaltfront von tief
ulrich schug heute die hochnebeldecke
über mitteleuropa ein bisschen zusammen
das merkten allerdings nicht sehr viele
von uns denn für viele blieb es einfach
trüb hin und wieder aber rissen die
wolken doch mal auseinander und sie
hatten einen kleinen sonnigen eindruck
deutlich besser klappte das hier an der
nordsee da rissen die wolken richtig
schön auf und da gab es dann
schauerwetter und diese schauer die
ziehen jetzt im laufe der nacht weiter
nach osten sonst bleibt es trüb zum teil
bildet sich auch wieder neuer bodennebel
und aus diesen beugen kann es auch mal
ein bisschen niesel die temperaturen
dazu sinken an der nordseeküste auf 8
bis 6 grad sonst geht's auf 5 bis 3 grad
runter und am kältesten wird es am
alpenrand morgen steigen die
temperaturen meist auf fünf bis zehn
grad an den küsten von ost und nordsee
werden es elf oder zwölf grad werden und
das ist dem etwas kräftigere wind starke
bis stürmische böen sind da durchaus
möglich zu verdanken denn dort gibt es
allerdings auch einige regen scheller
sonst es ist nachwievor trüb aber die
sonnen anteile nehmen zum beispiel hier
in sachsen auch im westen deutschlands
und am alpenrand in den nächsten tagen
ändert sich erst mal wenig es geht mit
wenig regen etwas sonne und nebel weiter
genannt